they're overfed oversexed and they're
over here the american signal crayfish
has taken over in the 1970s freshwater
crayfish tails were all the rage but our
puny native crayfish were considered too
small so farmers started breeding the
fatter and meteor american signal
crayfish big mistake the Americans took
over and 30 years on have invaded 85% of
our British rivers voted wiping out our
native crayfish and now they're
destroying our riverbanks we've got to
fight back fight back by eating as many
as we can there are over 250 million
American crayfish in our rivers Mike
Robinson owns a pub where there are
bestseller on the menu he's board Jack
and I deliver pang in Bowsher the shows
how to catch them I reckon that fish is
the best plate yeah because if you think
about it what do they probably the most
of his dead fish on the body of the
River Tyne they're scavengers slashing
yeah right that's irresistible to a
crayfish all we have to do is check it
in and tie it to a tree I mean it's like
the same process of a lobster pot
exactly yeah it's a perilous game this
you do need to get a license from the
Environment Agency to do this but just
like the crayfish they're free so this
is perfect too natural feeding around
for the crayfish yeah they're gonna come
out the bank and they're gonna smell
that and they'll come 100 yards upriver
to that bait go for it it's beautiful I
could catch 20 kilos of crayfish in here
in here in one night when the water
temperature yeah drops below 10 degrees
you can forget it really yeah they get
they hibernate they just go to sleep so
in the winter weather they go under the
river banks and that's when they caused
all the damage cuz they burrow deep to
get away from the cold and yeah they
just curl up and hang out Oh Jack look
no fish no there's a crayfish down there
where look just there here's a huge
crayfish he go he got idiot look at that
size of him how much like a lobster that
that is it my turn that's honestly that
I mean that's incredible just look at
that there though in terms of meat I
know and how much claw meats in there
it's unbelievable you look are from Jack
you're gonna keep your eye on it that's
your first crayfish okay let's go you
keep your eye on that
a crayfish are night feeders so you
leave the traps out overnight we're
collecting traps that might put down
yesterday if you were a prawn trapper in
the sea yeah you'd be delighted to get
that that's one night look at them
what would a native you know creatures
don't like I mean same color no they're
they're sort of pale paler whiter and
geller that's in that's an adult native
would be that size whereas these guys 5
to 6 inches long out if people ate them
more and more then it would help the
environment and it where can you go and
get 20 kilos of free prawns yeah if you
don't want to catch your own you can
order American freshwater crayfish from
your fishmonger now it's time to get
these critters home and into the pot
guess who caught the biggest crayfish
how she gums
they just give a little raise okay and
let's get cooking them shall we there's
a big one
well fresh crayfish it doesn't get any
better than this pleasing we turned into
the most amazing crayfish salad poorni
water and crayfish in and just watch
them change color now within seconds
they cook within two and a half or three
minutes max and look at the color of
them straight out
if you peel them when the warm they come
away from the shell that a lot easier
bodies off from the towel look at that
that is delicious
slow roasted tomatoes green salad
freshwater crayfish tails and
vinaigrette there you have a delicious
crayfish salad that cost [ __ ] all y'all
so both put that much in there yeah